all right pam's with us in birmingham
hey pam how are you
i'm wonderful how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well me and my husband helped retire in
about five years
um we have a hundred thousand dollars in
savings we we don't owe for anything and
have it in years
uh but that money is just sitting there
we do have some in stocks um
and so forth and
403 b
um how long has that been sitting
yeah 100 thousand just sitting there how
long has it been sitting there
uh we just built up to a hundred
thousand a few months ago oh okay okay
so your questions what
uh my question is should we invest that
in the stock market or some other place
we need to put it
um
you know a little a little bit leery
about the stock market with the economy
like it is we
back in 2008 like everyone else we lost
quite a bit no you didn't if you stayed
in
yeah well yeah we stayed in and it all
came back unless you bought the worst
stocks on the planet
uh no it didn't come back okay you
bought the water stocks on the planet
because the market yeah the market was
14 000 pre-2008 it was 18 000 until just
the other day
yeah so it came back when they came back
and then some
overall yeah pam i'm gonna i want this
money to work for me i mean right now
it's kicked back in a hammock sitting in
your savings account and i understand
you allowing you know some of it to be
there for an emergency fund uh but uh i
i need to put this money to work i mean
you guys have worked hard to earn it and
now it's just relaxing and so put it to
work get connect with an endorsed local
provider in your area talk with them
about the market talk with them about
your options your risk tolerance things
you can invest in dave one of the things
she said that that made the hairs on the
back of my neck stand up was stocks you
know and if she's messing around with
single stocks then you know that that is
one of those things where it's very
volatile it goes up and it goes down so
talk with that elp about growth stock
mutual funds talk with them about your
goal and your plan to retire and then
understand the investment vehicles get
this money out of the hammock put it to
work for you yeah here's the thing if
you put it in a good growth stock mutual
fund in 15 years it's going to be around
600 000 bucks
if you don't it's going to be around 110
000.
so this is something like a 500 000
hammock that chris is describing this is
a gold-lined
hammock
that's babysitting this money i mean
that's that's what's called opportunity
cost on your money when the money's not
working you've lost the opportunity for
it to work and sit down with a good
endorsed local provider and understand
the market once you understand the
cycles in the market when you see the
market drop like it is right now it
means you're at kmart baby the blue
light's on it's on sale this is the time
to get in not the time to get out and
dave i love that you brought up
opportunity costs because that's one of
the things i walked through at the
retire inspired event uh the opportunity
cost of debt when you have money going
out to pay a credit card debt or a car
loan now that money can't go work for
you and can't grow up
your five dollar bill can't grow up into
a fifty and so that is something people
need to look at and really understand
you're building the credit card
company's legacy or the car company's
legacy instead of your own when you have
a payment get that thing out of your
life so you can grow that money by
investing it yeah i mean i talked to a
guy one time years ago here on the on
the radio show and he had he had 300 000
in 100 bills
in a coffee can buried in his backyard
and i'm like dude number one that paper
is going to deteriorate and you're going
to lose all the money that was going to
turn into dust and number two when you
die your kids are going to be back there
with a dead gum metal detector trying to
find papa's stuff and number three that
300 000 would turn into three million in
about two eye blinks were you to invest
it so this coffee can has cost you
millions with an s
and that's what opportunity cost is
you're not investing it you think you're
protecting it but inflation and taxes
are kicking your butt during that decade
that you didn't invest it and dave that
300 000 in 10 years how much is it worth
what does it look like after inflation
goes up it looks more like what 270 yeah
exactly or less yeah because you're you
know you're losing money at that four
four and a half percent rate hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of wall street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim
[Music]
you